[Music]
we are so excited to have you on the
team to help us disrupt this toxic
culture around student loans higher
education
and parents and society and guidance
counselors there's like a thousand
villains that you can point at in this
situation oh yeah it's it's crazy right
now
debt has been so normalized in this
space we are selling 18 year olds debt
where they think that taking out student
loans that it's just normal that it's
just part of the process and that's not
okay i'm so proud of the work that
ramsey's done with borrowed future and
just
bringing light to that situation it
really disrupts that toxic culture and
it shows students you know this is not
the way to go and there are other ways
that we can fix this yeah there's
definitely a lie that was sold at least
to me and i know many many people out
there where we as a society we said hey
if you just do really good in school and
you get great grades you'll have an
amazing life you'll go to your dream
school and life's gonna work out for you
but unfortunately as you realize you i i
wanted to go to the school and i got in
and i thought oh my gosh i gotta prove
to my dream school and i got zero
dollars
and it was two hundred thousand dollars
for the four years
for
basically a film degree
and even not knowing dave back then i
was like this feels like a bad deal for
me i'm not doing this so i ended up
going to a state school i was out of
school for a year went back to school
finished up and still ended up with 36
thousand dollars in student loans and i
thought well i did better than 200 grand
that's the thing is i talk to students
all the time who just kind of shrug off
student loans like ah yeah it's no big
deal it's what everybody's doing it's
what all of my friends are doing and
it's important to highlight like it
doesn't have to be that way you know my
story i won a half a million dollars in
scholarships i was able to go to school
debt-free my mom really lit a fire in me
early she basically said my freshman
year you know christina you're on your
own for paying for college so you need
to figure out a strategy and i'm so
thankful she had that conversation early
on because it gave me time to think
about what i was doing and try to see
like are there other ways i can go to
college do i have to follow this notion
that you have to take out student loans
and i learned that you don't yeah it
really comes down to having a plan
having a strategy and having the
conversation early i mean we just i just
took a call
and she's got seven kids and she was
very honest with them and she said hey
you're on your own but i appreciate that
honesty versus i will figure it out
we'll figure it out and what figuring it
out looks like is co-signing hundreds of
thousands of dollars in loans and then
everyone's frustrated absolutely not a
solution yeah it's a tough pill to
swallow you know to tell your kids you
know we can't afford college it's hard
you know when my mom told me freshman
year of high school i was like why are
you telling me this i am a freshman what
can i do about it but at the same time
you know i knew she was just trying to
be real with me you know my dad he
passed away when i was seven from cancer
and my family struggled financially so
even though it was tough like i'm
thankful she had the courage to have
that conversation because it just it
needs to happen that conversation
doesn't need to be had with somebody
selling your students student loans it
needs to happen with parents yeah we
have a high school curriculum out there
uh through our ramsay education team and
i got the pleasure of hosting it and it
was so eye opening as i sat down with
high schoolers and i was asking them
basic questions where do you want to go
to school what do you want to do how
much do you think that'll pay how much
will that school cost and i didn't
realize it was going to be an
interrogation there were kids running
out of there crying after we were done
and i thought oh my gosh i'm the first
one to ask them these questions their
parents are not talking to them about
the future they're just going la la la
la i have shame and guilt and baggage
for my own financial past and we're just
not going to talk about money because
that's that's the healthy way to to
handle our families and having that
conversation as much as it might be
painful man it's so freeing in your
situation where you went okay at least i
know what i need to do now right exactly
a lot of kids don't have that wisdom and
insight early on even just career-wise a
lot of students think you know i have to
go to the fancy school if i'm going to
be successful like i have to go to a
name-brand school and a lot of those
schools cost seventy thousand dollars
and that's just not true you know if you
walk around ramsey it's a competitive
workplace you know we have amazing
people here and if you ask people where
they went to school a lot of people went
to community college a lot of people
went to an online school a lot of people
you know just took non-traditional
routes and they're still here working
next to people who did go to prestigious
schools so you know the reality is that
you don't have to go to the fancy school
to be successful that is true all across
workplaces in america you'll have
somebody sitting at a desk that went to
an ivy league and you'll have somebody
sitting right next to them that went to
community college so you have to just
find your own path to success that's
debt free oh yeah and these days with
the digital space that we live in
there's just so many opportunities i
mean mit has so many free courses out
there where you're learning the same
things that you would inside of the
classroom that would cost you you know
thousands upon thousands of dollars
right and now there's amazing
certificate programs you know there's
digital marketing certificate programs
there's all sorts of like coding
bootcamps and things that you can do
online that'll get you incredible jobs
that make great money so it's like think
outside of the box explore your options
there's not just one right path yeah and
that's one of those things that we need
to keep beating the drum on because
students do think well if i don't go to
college i'm a nobody like all of my
friends went and here i am in my in my
town and i'm just not going to have a
great life now well what's crazy is that
trade school that's still a great option
the trades are not going away and the
thing is is no matter how hard the
economy gets no matter what the world
looks like we still need electricians we
still need plumbers so it's like college
isn't the only right route it's the
right route for a lot of people but the
right route for a lot of people is going
to be trade school it's going to be all
these different options that are out
there so it's important to figure out
you know what is right for you what is
right for your student even if it
doesn't look like what everybody else
does yeah and one of the problems is we
live in such a comparison culture and
it's so it's so much about your your
status and social media and what i'm
seeing is the number one job that
students want is to be an influencer and
to be a youtuber and while that's great
that they want to have an impact in that
way and they want to be front and center
that's fine you know we're we're on
camera we're in front of microphones
there's nothing wrong with with wanting
that but i question the motive behind it
and the heart behind it and going man
what do you really want what do you
really want to apply full force in your
life what do you want to dig into what
is the topic what is the area of focus
and once you ask those questions you can
get to some really interesting answers
right exactly i also think like speaking
of comparison i think a lot of parents
fall into the comparison trap you know
i've heard parents talk to me and
complain to me that you know in the high
school environment all these parents are
talking about well where's your kid
going to school my kids going to an ivy
league my kids going to this fancy
school and they almost feel pressure to
have their kid go somewhere fancy or to
sign on the dotted line for a parent
that's so toxic that the parents are
using their their kids as a pawn to
elevate their status
or i went to this school therefore my
kid needs to go to this school too
because this is our legacy and they're
going for the football team and they're
going because of the landscaping and the
water slides in the world-class
cafeteria and we've lost our daggum
minds yeah there's just so much toxic
pressure in this space and what results
is student loans like that's what
happens when we don't have these
conversations about you know what's
actually going on and the challenges you
know people just end up getting kind of
roped in to that trap yeah so what can
parents do if you're a parent listening
out there and you're going all right
christina i haven't saved for my kids
college i gotta have this conversation
saying i can't i can't do this i can't
cash flow it for you what would you say
to that parent well the fact that they
even want to have real conversations
about money with their kids that's
amazing there are so many parents that
are scared to have that conversation or
they just don't think about having that
conversation so let your kids know what
they're going to be up against
financially you know have those real
conversations about where you guys are
what what are they going to be
responsible for when it comes to college
and their future and then take debt off
the table like you be the first person
to tell your kids we're not doing debt
like we're going to go a different
direction like that's not what we're
doing and then help them cast a vision
for their life i think a lot of kids you
know they leave high school and they
don't really know what they want to do
so it's so they're vulnerable when
they're out there but you know help them
cast a vision and connect the dots of
like what does it take to get there you
know they may not need a four-year
degree they may not need a master's
degree they may need that trade
certificate you know there's so many
different routes that just really lock
arms with them and help them figure out
what works for them i love it christine
ellis folks one of our newest ramsay
personalities focused on this toxic
student loan crisis you can see her in
our borrowed future documentary you can
stream that on apple tv google play
amazon you name it christina so awesome
having you on the team thanks for having
me i'm so thrilled to be here this is
the ramsay show